hello welcome to the debate on Sky News
I'm Martin Stanford here's our take on
developments brought together from
America the UK and around the world on a
wave of optimism is Trump the most
popular presidential candidate will
speak to a rival the death of Bobby what
can be done for the children of stardom
and the famous and time to upgrade will
10 be the savior for windows in less
than a week the 16 Republican candidates
will debate on TV why they should be
running for the White House now in a
moment we're going to speak to dr. ben
Carson one of the prime time
participants as usual the Democrat
commentator Geoffrey Robinson is
standing by for us in New York and the
conservative commentator Armstrong
Williams is out and about this week in
Washington Armstrong let's go to you
because you've been following the
politicians and let's disclose once
again you're involved with one of the
campaigns but isn't 16 candidates were
just simply ridiculous yeah for for
disclosure I've got the Ben Carson's are
confident and business manager you know
16 is not too much it's the American Way
there we're various racing some very
serious issues with terrorism but the a
lot of people realizing there's still
not a part of the American dream we're
having to deal with the Middle East
we're having a deal with different
issues that we've not confronted before
we're all fit the states now is it legal
for same-sex marriages we're dealing
with the the pipeline which is still up
in question and monomeric 'as future and
in the bottom line is that when you have
people who willing to admit their time
and their resources and their family to
participate in this thing called a
presidential election for what they have
to go through in this scrutiny and the
articles that is written about them we
should applaud them that is the American
Way we need more people who are more
committed to running for president
because we realize that this country
needs me leader ship and so it's like a
buffet there's more to choose from and
it makes each other accountable
only in the Republican field but in the
Democratic field also it's a good thing
it's starting to something I don't think
we should even criticize okay well let
me bring in Jeffrey here in which case
if Armstrong's right and of course you
may well be you guys are on the Left who
got it completely wrong but it looks
like you've only got one person going
for this job yeah we've got the next
president of the United States what's
going to happen during the debates is
you're going to see 15 clowns and one
quasi serious candidate who won't get
the nomination because you can't get the
nomination and the only reason to watch
this debate is not for any of those 14
people it's for Donald Trump because
he's going to run away with this thing
he's the showman he knows what he's
going to do the rest of them are they're
jokes I mean it's ridiculous absolutely
ridiculous of Armstrong smorgasbord is
is filled with painted food you're going
to get food poisoning well before you're
too rude to the mall Jeffrey let's talk
to one of them shall we which is
Armstrong's associate and one of the
Republican presidential candidates just
a couple of weeks ago was topping the
polls that's dr. ben Carson thank you
for your time dr. Carson what do you
make of Donald Trump's according to
Jeffrey runaway success at this very
early stage well you have to recognize
that it's a marathon it's not a sprint
and that things will alternate people
will go up people will go down but the
important thing is that we have a
process in place whereby the American
people will have an opportunity to hear
actual solutions because the problems
are very significant right now you know
we have incredible divisiveness and
hatred you have a financial situation
that is incredibly unstable most people
don't recognize how precarious the
financial situation is and we have
radical jihadists who are very
interested in our demise these are
serious issues along with a host of
others and we have to have real
solutions for them but with all due
respect doesn't it feel like this may be
a paucity of ideas if one figure or
maybe two or three figures have not
managed to rise
is in the standing of the American
people to be the black clip candidates
for this top job well interestingly what
will begin to happen next week with the
debates is that a lot of people will
have an opportunity to hear from
individuals that they don't really know
they may have heard their name they may
have not heard their name but they'll
have an opportunity to actually hear
them as opposed to what other people
have said about them and I think it will
be a very eye-opening experience thank
you for a moment let me bring in Stacey
Hilliard a Republican commentator who's
based in London who also joins us in
this Stacy this is an extraordinary show
isn't it that there are so many would-be
candidates with only a year in this
process ready to go well I think it's
quite astounding that we have 15
candidates with so many of them being
very qualified to be the next president
united states i completely disagree with
jeffrey i believe the republicans have
the next president united states and
within that field of 15 we have a number
of governors who have very strong
records on improving the economy within
their states i'm building employments of
improving education i think we have a
very strong field and we have people
like dr. Carson are not afraid to speak
out against the kind of Washington elite
and the Democrats simply don't have that
and I think what you'll see with
Republicans are something different in
actual solutions uh it's volatile
situation though isn't it even this far
out from the actual finale next November
and that is you know it was all about
another Clinton Bush candidacy we
discussed it on this show only a matter
of weeks ago where's Jeb Bush gone what
you know Jeb is out there campaigning
hard I met with some of his team here in
London a few weeks ago and you know I
think they're looking at the campaign in
a very pragmatic a way that you know we
have Hillary who's not engaging with the
media at all who's actually roping them
off I'm but you have Jeb who's actually
out there shaking hands meeting people
and he has a record to run on you know
his biggest threat is his name Hillary's
biggest threat is her record I think
there's a big difference there and that
Jeb along with many of the other
candidates they have a real record that
able to run on Jeffrey I mean in terms
of the process because it's kind of what
all we can talk about right now it's
interesting isn't it that after that
myriad of debates last time of various
tiers and local station stage in them
and so on the Republican Party have said
over the next few months there will be
just nine I mean just nine and the whole
thing is complete idiocy I mean Stacy
represented a group called what the
Republicans in Europe or Republicans in
Britain that has since been disbanded
that foreshadows what's happening to the
Republican Party they're about to be
disbanded by having 14 or 13 complete
Schmucks running for president who
nobody in America is absolutely it ever
going to love elect see what the problem
is stacy and armstrong and ben Carson
are all standing on the decks of the
Titanic trying to convince America the
iceberg is beautiful we've already hit
that iceberg Jeffrey we've already hit
that with the current president we're
not standing on the deck so that science
Henrik we're actually trying to rescue
the country and that's what we're trying
to do you don't have candidates you're
able to do that and we are my fart yes
and we're trying to prevent something
that's already happened you don't have a
viable candidate except Jeb Bush who
won't get the nomination because the
Republican Party is disintegrating as we
speak you're a bunch of jokes all of you
on the and the debate next week is not
about Republicans having coming up with
coming up with great ideas because you
have no ideas the debate next week is
watching Donald Trump destroy every one
of these jobs including ben Carson are
you fearful that Donald Trump's about to
destroy you dr. Carson not in the
slightest and the the good thing is you
know credit travel around the country
before just tremendous crowds with a
great enthusiasm to in fact understand
what is going on are waking up I've had
so many people who have never voted
before never contributed before who've
gotten involved we have over 300,000
donations which is growing every day I'm
not necessarily going after the big
money or the special interest groups
because this is a country that was
supposed to be about the people for of
and by the people not
urban by the government not four of them
by the special interest groups and I
think the promise of America is yet to
be realized and I think it can be a
great nation which can lead the world in
the right direction once again but just
Armstrong on this on this question of
process and how exhausting it'll be I
know you think it's it's good thing that
there are so many candidates still vying
for this but there was a feeling wasn't
just looking back that the leadership of
the party felt that Mitt Romney got
weakened last time around by this
constant debate here debate they're
rehearsing the arguments and maybe there
was an argument that less is more you
know every election cycle is different
and I think the issues that we face
today define the kind of leadership that
we need I I'd find it very disheartening
that my colleague Jeffrey would refer to
any of these candidates as clowns and is
stupid is so beneath them I mean may I
finish I mean I just find it to be so
rude and so disrespectful for someone
who calls themself as a professional
matter how you feel about people what
they represent we as professionals where
the world listen to us should never
refer to people who are accomplished as
clowns we shouldn't do that then we
should always we should always have the
dignity of our role to show respect
especially with people who take their
time to come on this show to be a part
of the rest of this broadcast and with
that said yes these it demands different
times and people said the same thing I
when this guy by the name of Barack
Hussein Obama were running against
Hillary Clinton they thought he was a
joke and had no chance with a Muslim
name of winning the White House and he
has shown us that he was able to win
none of us know the future that's why as
dr. Carson says this is a marathon we
must run the race and let the American
people decide in 2016 and November their
choice of President of the United States
run the race this is a good thing
there's the point Jeffrey I mean what
are you afraid of you've got a congress
against the democratic party you've got
a whole bunch of people who want to be a
Republican president what are you guys
afraid of absolutely nothing i'm
thrilled with it i'm thrilled with
Donald Trump destroying the Republican
Party because they're a bunch of
numbskulls absolutely I mean then Carson
is the only person in America while his
support is packing CNN today's got him
barely in the top 10 by next week he'll
be out he's the only person in America
who doesn't understand that politically
he's a joke the rest of I mean he's
talking about enormous crowds 400 people
500 people his support is tanking
they're all tanking only only Donald
Trump is is coming through the crowd Jeb
Bush is tanking I mean it's the iceberg
guys it's right in front of you it ain't
beautiful you're sinking you're drowning
dr. Carson would you welcome the
possibility if Donald Trump actually has
his moment in the sunshine for the next
month or so and then come the fall come
Christmas he actually stands aside and
maybe the debate gets a little more
serious which is the kind of guy I think
you are well you know I I want the
process to work the way it's supposed to
I want people to have an opportunity to
hear everybody including Donald Trump
and what the solutions are because the
problems that we face are so significant
that you know engaging and hyperbole and
foolishness is not going to get us where
we need to be right now this is a very
serious time not only in the history of
the United States but in the history of
the world Stacey Hilliard from your
perspective how does this complicated
set of debates help the discussion and
the wider political discourse do you
think in America do you think this
number of nine they're scattering them
out on their there pacing them out over
the next few months is this going to
work better you think for everyone this
time around I'm I still think there is a
risk of overexposure of our candidates
I'm not necessarily from a picking them
apart side of it but I think that they
need to be out there campaigning meeting
with the people more than being on
debates i think that the field will
naturally come out and i'm interested
that can i just--can i just get you to
qualify that i'm surprised that you feel
that the what the the actually speaking
in the town halls or it you know
airports or bus stations or wherever it
might be that is still important in
these
days of the electronic Facebook
elections absolutely I think I'm you
know you look at people i look at my
parents as kind of a litmus test they're
very politically aware of it not
politically active and they're people
who get tired of being bombarded by mail
they get tired of being bombarded by
phone calls through social media they
want to have that connection with the
candidate that's missing and that
personal interaction with candidates is
no longer there and getting out there
and actually getting out there shaking
hands knocking on doors talking in the
town hall is calling people together and
that could be a virtual town hall as
well but pulling people together and
actually hearing the voice of the
electorate people are angry and I think
that's something that the Republican
Party is actually recognizing and you
have people like Senator Ted Cruz and
dr. Carson who are actually speaking out
for those people who are disillusioned
with the way that Washington is working
and I think that's something that the
Democrats don't realize they don't
realize that America's actually just fed
up with the way things have been and I
think if the candidates can actually get
out there and interact with the
electorate more it'll benefit them I
think debates are great I'm and they
have a purpose and they have a place but
I think there is a risk of creating a
bit of appetite I lack of I'm enthusiasm
from the electorate by having too many
debates and overexposure Stacy Leo thank
you very much indeed so Jeffrey we're
into this season then the debates kick
off next week I think there's a front
not the frontrunners go late at night
don't know and there's a sort of tea
time warm-up debate for the people who
are less well-known do you think that'll
work out okay no of course not the
people who were less well-known will
fall is it not by the way is not a
marathon it's a hurdle it's a
steeplechase and one by one the law for
with the hurdle but a cardinal fought
the first or second hurdle he's gone I
mean there's no way that he's considered
a serious candidate and when Stacy talks
about ben Carson and Ted Cruz Stacy be
careful what you wish for I would even
send money to Ted Cruz I would love it
if he was the cabinet because you're not
going to find a better representative of
the stupidity with a Republican Party
than Ted Cruz go for it Ted dr. Carson a
final word to you if we may on that very
issue that Stacy was talking
about her trying to change Washington I
seem to remember there was a candidate
now what was his name buraq something
Barack Obama who said he was going to
fix Washington and persuade the American
people the process was broken didn't go
too well for him did it well you know I
actually think that he was very
successful in what he was trying to do
but his vision of America is very
different than my vision and the vision
of millions of other Americans and
really this election is going to be
about that particular debate which way
do we want to go do we want to have a
nation that is up for and by the people
or up for and by the government and are
we going to embrace the original vision
of our nation or we're going to move
more toward the European model and I
think it's a legitimate discussion and
American people have the opportunity and
the right to make the decision which way
they want to go dr. ben Carson good to
talk to you thank you I pleasure
a reminder you can catch up with the
scan use debate on apple TV on roku on
catch up and of course at Sky News calm
/ us it's been a devastating week for
the family of Bobbi Kristina Brown but
what her death has achieved is
highlighting the pressures of young
adults particularly those living amongst
stardom having famous parents and
perhaps easy access to drugs well Jamie
Foster Brown the founder of Sister to
Sister magazine is in Washington what
can we learn from Bobbi Brown's death do
you think I coined the phrase are the
domestic violence of bling and I talked
about because I'm around so many
celebrities and their children and I see
how the children come up or under the
celebrity of their parents and the
parents have to be able to take time to
help the child to find out who they are
if you're you're appointed to a family
where there's looks as voices as dancers
all these things that are there and you
have nothing where where do you fit you
become an appendage of the parent and I
think and I see this all the time with a
lot of the celebrity celebrities family
said ideal we're so there I don't think
anyone there's no counseling there's
nothing is all about you know may get
out there make that sale create that
brand and there's no one that pays
attention to it except I Tom Cruise I
will say this that I learned some time
ago that Tom Cruise was like that his
kids have to mow that lawn and they have
to wash those dishes and they have to do
the laundry I was told the story once
that the kids didn't do their chores and
they went out to go rock climbing and
Tom got in the car with and got them and
brought them back home this is my house
I bought this house I paid for all this
you don't necessarily that he had to
teach the kids they had to earn their
way they can't just come up under the
parent and I thought that was brilliant
and we need more of that in our in that
celebrity world because we lose a lot of
our children we lose a lot of our swag
Arthur well let's just bring in Geoffrey
Robinson who's in New York and Armstrong
Williams who's out of the office in
Washington today Armstrong let me come
to you on this it's a mammoth challenge
parenting for anyone isn't it but if
you're a celebrity if you're very
wealthy I guess there are extra risks
are there in this process of bringing up
children you know I in my perspective
Jamie Foster Brown who would not lose
very modest was very close to Whitney
Houston in her daughter Bobbi Kristina
and I know this is very devastating for
her but I think what she hit on our
values and self-worth and doing
something on your own and having your
own self-worth in credibility and when
she spoke about that appendage where
your identity is that you are the
daughter of such and such and you've
never earned anything in your own built
something on your own you're always
seeking for something that gives you
that fulfillment and sometimes when you
don't find that fulfillment you try to
find it in relationships you try to find
it in things that can ultimately destroy
you eternally and the story that she
told about Tom Cruise you gotta teach
them about work ethic you have to teach
them why the food is on the table and
why mommy and daddy are able to provide
you these kinds of things and sometimes
these parents are not parents because
they're not at home and these kids are
being raised by nannies and they never
earned the right value systems know if
they didn't have a dime but they did not
have their parents name they had an
identity and a seraph word that gives
them the kind of foundation for them to
really become something in life not
really based on money and materialism
but being based on something else that
gives them value and so that is so
missing the day and so you take that in
any family it doesn't have to be a
celebrity family it could be just an
ordinary family if you don't have
something deeper the materialism
something that we call faith and
something that gives you a foundation of
that where you really know who you are
and what your lineage is this is will be
the outcome if you don't have those
strong pillars in your life to save you
a rescue you Jeffrey do you think that
the parenting challenge is is enormous
and particularly when you're on under
today's total 24-7 media spotlight
oh absolutely absolutely and and that
Jamie brings up the story of Tom Cruise
I have a number of friends on the west
coast who are instantly recognizable who
do little things like make sure that
they have a family dinner every night
the kids and and the parents are at
dinner every night the door is always
open they can always talk it's very hard
to compete with your parents and those
parents who are raising their kids I
think in a very healthy way make the
kids understand they don't have to
compete it's not it's not a contest now
I mean we watch we all watch the Whitney
Houston funeral and every single person
who spoke at that funeral at one point
turned to Bobbi Kristina and said we're
there for you and I want to ask Jamie
the day after the funeral how many of
those people really were there for
Christine I say workers apparently Tyler
Perry was there he's there for her now
that he's there now trying to help the
family but not really I mean Bobbi
Kristina even though she lived in
Atlanta she has a lot of relatives in
Atlanta on the brown side she kind of
stayed to herself and stayed with this
guy Nick somehow he was on a security
blanket for her and he was a security
blanket for Whitney when she was alive
and she was a filming sparkle when they
were up in Detroit during all during
that time every night thing she went
through a particular restaurant and she
ordered a hamburger and some sort of
Matt margarita but one of those drinks
and and she was always with Nick that's
when I first learned about Nick Gordon
was when Whitney was with him and she
called him her son and he was like a
security security blanket for her but
Bobbi Kristina it wasn't like everybody
was there for her you know people forget
and people move on and they were it
wasn't like she was the sweetest thing
but she wasn't like she was out there
with those people all the time she Tyler
trying to try her out as an actor
actress I think he put her in one of his
um one of his shows and he I remember he
said oh she did real good and
Bobby told me jamie tyler said quits
Bobby christy is very very well but you
didn't hear much about her except for
when she was out there with that guy and
all the end then when that bathtub Jamie
can I just can I just jump in here it is
it really this difficult that is there
something to think in the American Way
that kind of expects celebrity or
success to trickle down through the
family is it really difficult for
instance to the son or daughter of a
famous person or a celebrity to say I'm
going to go another path i'm going to be
a physician or a nurse or you know a
more modest profession is it possible to
do that in America and I think is
possible if the person has who they are
and that unless up to the parent to help
them find out who they are and that's up
to the parent to give the true to
channel some challenges so that the
child can see I can do this I am I'm
okay i don't need the parent has to move
the child as much away from their
celebrity life as possible so that the
child has a has the room to grow as
their own individual it is very very
difficult because you're sucked in a lot
you know where your parent goes you go
you're at the parties and you're a dare
drink and remember who drew the little
girl what am i thinking of a hug she was
drinking at 89 years old drew barrymore
gosh people start thinking of these kids
that which she was an actress but they
start thinking of the kids as if they're
grown the kids are not grown they're
still kids but there are some who move
away there because they go into
management they may you know be on them
on the outside of the rock and roll
business okay yeah Jamie thank you for
your time today Jamie Foster Braun thank
you very much you're welcome
next logging out of a system error and
logging in to a new era what should we
expect from Windows 10 well let's bring
in Jeffrey and Armstrong once again
Jeffrey you go first here are you a
windows kind of guy no I'm my kids have
assured me that I'm now old enough for
Apple and we're a whole Apple family but
let me say this the world is divided
clearly divided into two and a half
camps this is the Apple camp the windows
camp and then there's a bunch of geeky
lunatics who use onyx or whatever that
thing is cool but the what's interesting
about Windows is not windows it's
microsoft if you look at the battle
between window Microsoft and Apple what
you're looking at is rocky and Apollo
Creed that's the battle and you know
what no matter who wins it's really good
for boxing I'm strong you know a thing
about marketing you know a thing about
running a business what do you reckon to
Microsoft's effort to finally get a
ubiquitous product that's going to work
on a tablet on a phone or your PC at
home well they have to do it or they'll
be left behind I'm an apples kind of guy
I'll always be a nap us kind of guy
there will always be people who will
never leave when does because there's a
device that they're custom to they're
addicted to it they're always build
market for it I would say there's a
diminishing market but I think Microsoft
is very wise to get to the times because
they see what is technology is going and
they don't want to be left behind good
to talk to you guys thanks again
Armstrong and Jeffrey and that's it for
this edition of the debate you can
continue watching sky news on Apple TV
Roku and catch up and of course on Sky
News calm until next time goodbye
you